Prof: So we are going to
talk today about two of the most
significant episodes of Part II
of the Quixote,
episodes that mark a transition
to--
that begin the sort of the down
slope of the novel as it moves
towards its conclusion.
It is a protracted culmination
and finale consistent
with the slower more deliberate
pace of Part II.
We will be meeting one
character from Part I,
who reappears,
Ginés de Pasamonte,
under the guise of master
puppeteer Master Peter,
and there will not only be
repetitions of episodes from
Part I,
but even repetitions of
episodes from Part II within
Part II.
After the episodes that I will
discuss today,
three major new developments
occur.
First, that Don Quixote will
sometimes leave the center of
the action to be replaced by
Sancho.
Second, that both Don Quixote
and Sancho become the objects of
amusement for frivolous upper
class characters who have read
Part I.
And three, that the protagonist
will be surrounded by many more
characters than before.
The overarching theme of the
novel continues to be
desengaño as most
of the action is staged by
internal authors.
It is an action that is highly
theatrical and the props or
backstage of the skits are
revealed to the reader,
either during the performance
or right after.
The first of the two important
episodes is the one about Don
Quixote's descent into
Montesinos cave,
a truly remarkable tour de
force and one of the most
brilliant scenes in the Western
literary tradition.
So Montesinos cave,
this is one of the principle
episodes of Part II and arguably
of the entire work because it
seems to engage the main
literary topics and sources of
the novel and also provides a
rare glimpse into the inner
workings of Don Quixote's
subconscious.
It is as if we were looking
behind the scenes of the
Quixote or allowed to see
its reverse side,
as we see the reverse side of
that painting within Las
Meninas that
Velázquez is working on.
It is also as if were allowed
to dissect the protagonist while
he's still alive.
Let us first notice that this
is an adventure that Don Quixote
seeks,
that he looks for it,
not one that is imposed on him
by chance,
like the encounters on the road
or by other characters who are
scripting his life.
As we have seen,
Sansón Carrasco from the
very beginning is trying to
script Don Quixote's life,
and there will be several
author internal authors doing
that,
but this is not the case at all.
This is an episode,
an adventure that Don Quixote
wants to undertake,
and he tells the scholar or the
cousin that he wants to do so
and asks how to get to
Montesinos' cave.
It is also an episode that is
strictly Spanish,
and that seems to take Don
Quixote into the depths of the
Spanish soil:
it is as if saying that these
kinds of fabulous events also
happen in Spain and in the
present,
although, as you will see,
and I will speak about the
sources of the episode descents
into caves and so forth,
but this is one that is based
on a Spanish tradition;
that is, people knew about
Montesinos cave and talked about
it--they exist--and Don Quixote
wanted to go into them;
he decided that he had to have
this adventure.
One way to see the episode as
flowing from Camacho's
wedding--which is the big
episode preceding it--is through
its connection with Ovid.
The cousin or scholar,
who is their guide,
is writing a Spanish Ovid,
and the explanation given about
the rivers of Spain and their
names is in the spirit of the
Metamorphoses.
This scholar is another satire
of students and intellectuals,
like the one that we seen in
the case of Sansón
Carrasco;
this is even more extreme,
this is a really ridiculous
scholar who is trying to find
out who had the first cold in
history, if you remember.
And so, I also said that in
Part II of the Quixote
Cervantes seems to be signaling
as his sources Homer,
Virgil, Ovid and,
as we shall see,
Dante,
as if claiming that his work is
their worthy successor:
that he's in their league,
as it were, in common parlance.
I will speak about Virgil when
we get to meet Altisidora,
the character that you will
meet and find very amusing,
who is a version of Dido.
Now, this descent into the cave
has antecedents in the
Odyssey,
the Aeneid,
and the Divine Comedy,
of course.
Although there are also sources
in chivalric romances,
this is an adventure on a
higher literary level,
this is not just going back to
episodes in the chivalric
romances but Homer,
Virgil, Dante.
There are, of course,
also traditional stories about
going into caves in all cultures
and in all literatures.
If you have read your American
literature you see that in Tom
Sawyer,
and Huckleberry Finn,
and so forth,
there are episodes where the
characters go into caves,
but here, I think,
the sources are those that I
mentioned.
Going down into the cave has,
of course,
deep psychological resonances,
having to do with Don Quixote's
sexuality,
and concomitantly his fear of
death.
As he enters the cave he has to
walk away at the brambles
covering the entrance in actions
that are symbolic or reminiscent
of a deflowering,
and the blackbirds that fly
away in fright are clear
intimations of death;
they are bad omens;
they have kind of a
Hitchcock-like air to me,
I mean, to modern readers.
They, I'm sure,
remind you of that very
frightening Hitchcock film
The Birds.
What Don Quixote experiences in
the cave is a dream and,
of course, this aligns it with
dream literature.
This is clear by his being
asleep when he is pulled back
up,
and from the story he tells
about falling asleep when he
sits down on the coiled up rope
within the cave.
Don Quixote says that he wakes
up from that sleep,
but it is obvious that he
awakens within the dream,
that this is a dream within a
dream,
another mirror effect.
What the dream allows is for
the untrammeled emergence of Don
Quixote's deepest fears in the
form of stories related to his
fantasies or drawn from his
fantasies.
It is as if he had been
administered a drug,
a truth serum,
or as if he had relaxed on the
psychoanalyst couch,
and allowed himself to free
associate.
The story of Durandarte and
Belerma is drawn from the
Carolingian cycle.
Remember that I mentioned the
various cycles of the chivalric
romances and the epics and the
Carolingian is from Charlemagne,
and so forth.
They're drawn from the
Carolingian cycle and seems to
have embedded not only the fear
of death, but the fear of
castration.
All of the characters,
except for Merlin,
are from the ballads of the
Carolingian and Arthurian cycle:
King Arthur,
Charlemagne.
The characters are supposed to
be dead and everyone is in
mourning, and the procession is
kind of a mournful procession
as--like a burial.
Durandarte's body in the story
has his heart removed and sent
to Belerma as a symbol of his
undying love;
this is the original story.
He asked when he died to have
this heart removed and sent to
his beloved.
Here his castrated cadaver,
as it were, appears as the
statue grazing his own tomb
unable to speak.
But the veracity of the story
is compromised,
or grotesquely guaranteed,
by Montesinos' explanation that
he has had to salt the heart so
that it will not rot and begin
to smell.
This destroys the fantasy.
I mean, if this great hero has
his heart sent to his beloved,
one never thinks that this
heart will be subject to the
laws of nature,
this is fantasy world;
but here, that fantasy is
destroyed and the story--
the veracity of the story,
in other words,
can be guaranteed by the fact
that they have to salt it so
that it won't rot.
Natural laws threaten the
story's verisimilitude.
A jerk-beef heart is not the
same as the heart that
symbolizes love,
courage and masculinity.
The heart, of course,
has all of these connotations.
So if you think of it as being
made of jerk-beef all of those
connotations are destroyed or
become grotesque.
Although time is flexible
within the episode its effects
on flesh are present;
that is, impinging other
aspects.
I say that the time is flexible
as was in the episode because,
how long was Don Quixote down?
The scholar and Sancho say an
hour, at most;
he says three days!
And then there is the issue of
how long ago these stories
occurred, hundreds of years ago,
yet these characters are there.
So time within the story is
flexible, as time tends to be,
as we know, in dreams.
We know now from modern studies
in dreams that stories that seem
to take a long time actually
take a few seconds in a dream,
and that there is this
compression that Freud talks
about,
how a dream compresses stories
in a very short time.
This is intimated here,
in that Don Quixote says that
he's been there for three days
and they say only an hour.
But the effect of time on flesh
is evident.
Now, this detail of the effect
of time on flesh reveals Don
Quixote's own doubts about the
legitimacy of chivalric legends.
I mean, remember,
this is a story he himself is
telling,
so if the story comes up in
this subconscious it's because
he has doubts about the
legitimacy of the chivalric
legends.
The stories,
those of the chivalric legends,
violate natural law,
hence they are fantastic,
as other characters have been
telling him all along,
and all of this seems to have
had an effect on him.
Now, Don Quixote is recognized
as a great knight,
a constant that began with
Sansón Carrasco's
revelation of the existence of
Part I,
and this is something that will
happen over and again in Part
II,
that he is recognized as a
great knight,
but in this case by character's
whose own existence is very,
very doubtful,
and that he himself will doubt
from now on by asking others
anxiously,
like Maese Pedro's--;like
Master Peter's monkey,
if what happened in the cave
was real,
and by insisting that Sancho
believe that it was real and
striking deals with him:
"I'll believe that if you
believe the cave of
Montesinos,"
it shows that he's not that
sure about it.
So their recognition;
that is, the recognition of his
being a great knight by these
characters is hardly an
assurance.
I am underlining these doubts
that the stories reveal about
his own fantasies,
but the most disturbing part of
the story is the appearance of
Dulcinea in the guise of the
ugly wench that Sancho tried to
make him believe was his lady.
This is--we know from Freud,
Freud's great book,
The Interpretation of Dreams
that was published in 1900,
when he talks about the remains
of the day,
how a dream picks up elements
from the previous day and
incorporates them into stories,
and this is sort of the remains
of the day.
Now, the appearance of this
wench convinces Sancho that Don
Quixote is insane because he was
the author of that charade,
but it also shows to what
extent that episode of the three
peasant women has shaken Don
Quixote's own beliefs and probed
deep into the sources of his own
desires for Dulcinea and of his
invention of Dulcinea.
This peasant Dulcinea who
smells of raw garlic,
as you remember,
as she smelled of sweat in
Sancho's earlier story about
her,
when he said:
'I got next to her and she
smelled a little bit because she
was pitching hay or whatever it
was.'
This peasant Dulcinea is,
I think, is close to Don
Quixote's own real desire for
Aldonza Lorenzo,
the original Dulcinea.
It seems to be the repressed
desire for a vulgar physically
strong sexually aggressive
younger woman who is the very
opposite,
in fact, is the co-relative
opposite of his idealization of
her.
The more vulgar this woman of
his desires is,
the more idealized she will
become in his fantasy.
Also, when asked for a loan by
her in this hilarious,
hilarious part of the
story--the last thing you
imagine is for Dulcinea asking
for a loan from Don Quixote--
which is going to be backed up,
by the way, the guarantee is an
intimate--an inner garment of
Dulcinea's;
this is a very elaborate
underskirt of sorts,
and it's going to be the
guarantee--I mean,
these things are highly
sexualized.
But Don Quixote is short two
reales: she wants six,
but he has only four left to
give her.
This is a clear sign of his
deep and repressed fear of
sexual inadequacy--it couldn't
be clearer;
you don't have to be
Freud--which may be the source
of his heroic fantasies.
He's old, he feels sexually
inadequate, so he wants to
imagine himself a young vigorous
knight who can go and fight and
seduce maidens.
So Sancho's invention in the
episode of the enchanted
Dulcinea has dug deep into Don
Quixote's dreads and into the
source of his fantasies.
In this topsy-turvy world of
the cave there are eerie images
of death, also.
I already mentioned the
blackbirds at the mouth of the
cave.
Durandarte's cadaver posing as
a statue on its own sarcophagus
is the eeriest of them all and
the uncanniest,
it's an inversion.
The statue on a sarcophagus
presumably represents the body
of the dead person within it--
I'm sure you have been to
European cathedrals,
where you go and you find all
of these sarcophagi and you see
on top the recumbent statue of
the person within it,
kings and all of that who are
usually like this with their
hands like this,
and they have their swords near
them and all of that--
I find that eerie enough to
begin with,
but in any case--here,
however, the cadaver is the
statue;
nature has replaced art,
or has become art.
Do you understand?
Instead of having a
representation you have
literally the cadaver on top of
the sarcophagus.
But let us not forget that we
are dealing here with death and
also in the realm of
temporality;
if you remember that
Durandarte's heart was salted so
that it would not smell.
How can the cadaver replace the
statue and not rot like its
heart?
Art has been taken over by
death, too;
this is what the intimation is.
Nothing, not even art,
is immune from death in this
world of the cave.
There may be a pun,
a ghoulish pun embedded here:
sarcophagus comes from the
Greek sarcos,
flesh and phagein,
to eat.
The sarcophagus literally eats
flesh, the flesh of the dead
body that it contains,
but here the dead body has
escaped to become its own
statue.
This is a very baroque image.
We will meet--we will find
another sarcophagus that we will
be discussing in the course of
the next few chapters.
Now, the stories and images
within Montesinos cave highlight
the central topic of Part II
desengaño.
Desengaño,
as we have seen can mean the
destruction of all illusions.
When Don Quixote comes to,
after emerging from the cave,
he declares,
in what is a classic expression
of desengaño,
and this is a quote:
"Forgive ye, friends,
[he tells the scholar and
Sancho]
for having brought me away from
the most pleasing and charming
life and sight,
that ever mortal saw or lived.
In short, I am now thoroughly
satisfied that all of the
enjoyments of this life pass
away like a shadow or a dream,
and fade away like the flower
of the field.
O unhappy Montesino!
O desperately wounded
Durandarte!
O unfortunate Belerma!
O weeping Guadiana!
And ye unlucky daughters of
Ruydera, whose waters show what
floods of tears stream from your
fair eyes!"
He says a bit later,
quote: "I awaked,
and found myself,
I knew not by what means,
in the midst of the finest,
pleasantest,
and most delightful meadow,
that nature could create,
or the most pregnant fancy
imagined."
Unquote.
This is the locus
amoenus of Renaissance,
pastoral literature that I have
mentioned before--
you remember the locus
amoenus into which Rocinante
wanders and falls in love with
the mares and all of that.
It is a topic of Renaissance
literature as the most pleasant
of place, and this is where he
lands, and presumably where he
has his dream.
Desengaño,
as I have been saying,
means to peel away the
illusion, the delusion.
It is a form of self-analysis,
of recognition comparable to
the one in today's terms
achieved through psychoanalysis.
Don Quixote seems to have dived
into this own subconscious.
Is this a regressus ad
uterum, an atavistic return
to the womb?
That's the Latin way of saying
it, return to the womb,
regressus ad uterum.
It's an atavistic return to the
womb;
I mean, it's trying to get back
into the mother's womb,
seeking solace and refuge.
Don Quixote's descent,
as we have seen,
makes him look harshly upon
himself.
It does not completely shake
his beliefs or dispel his
madness, but it is a serious
blow, and from now on he will
act saner.
How can it have been
pleasurable, however?
Only if one thinks that once in
the cave he was at least in the
living presence of his
fictions--
this was pleasurable--and that
the disillusionment became
repressed,
as he experienced it.
When he met all of these
elements that threatened his
disillusions he repressed them
immediately,
and that--as we tend to repress
unpleasant experiences--
that he was not aware,
as we readers are,
that what he experienced
threatened his beliefs.
So he comes back with doubts,
but are not conscious doubts.
Now, everything seems to
converge in the scene of the
Montesinos cave:
Don Quixote's belief in the
authenticity of the romances of
chivalry and the reality of what
he sees when he sees windmills,
for instance, are questioned.
The topics of the courtly love
tradition,
which had filtered into the
romances of chivalry tumble
through literalization by their
being put through the
requirements of natural law.
I already alluded several times
to Durandarte's salted heart;
Belerma, for her part,
may have looked under the
weather because she had her
menstrual period,
thought not really it is
explained, because the problem
was that she is menopausal.
Real time, and with it,
periodic bodily functions,
age and aging and decay have
crept into the world of fiction
contained in the cave.
No harsher way to dispel the
idealization of a Renaissance
beauty than to imagine her
menstruating or going through
menopause,
meaning that she's already aged;
imagine Botticelli's Venus's
with those problems,
it's grotesque!
It's brilliant;
however, to subject these
idealizations to temporality,
and temporality here means that
the age, that they suffer a
menstrual period.
Why would Dulcinea need a loan?
It is said that need or
necessity is everywhere in
passing;
the world of magic is invaded
by needs and physical laws and
what ensues are grotesque
images.
Now, there are many literary
antecedents to the cave of
Montesinos episode,
and I have already mentioned:
Homer, Virgil and Dante,
but the originality of the
episode is not so much the
descent into the cave as that it
reveals Don Quixote's
subconscious.
This is Cervantes' way of
showing us the knight's mind
from within, unencumbered by
reason.
As such, it seems to be a
better device than the soliloquy
in Shakespeare or in
Calderón,
which are parallel devices to
show what a character's thoughts
are: "to be or not to
be",
and so forth,
and in Calderón
"¡Ay,
mísero de
mí!"--
this is from the Life is a
Dream.
It is also more modern and
acceptable,
this device in Cervantes,
to contemporary readers,
it seems to me,
because no one goes around
delivering soliloquies that are
perfectly structured
rhetorically.
I'm sure you haven't heard any
of your friends going around
delivering soliloquies that are
so poetically well wrought.
But telling a dream is a common
activity, not only to
psychoanalysts,
you tell your dreams to your
friends.
In the episode there is a
grotesque combination of
fantasy, and not just reality
but the possible,
all having to do with the decay
of human flesh.
But as I have suggested,
isn't this also a tale of
castration fear?
These are the repressed figures
in Don Quixote's mind.
Peter Dunn, who was a very good
hispanist,
a British hispanist who taught
for many years,
at the end of his career at
Wesley University nearby,
wrote the following in a very
good article on this episode.
Actually, Peter Dunn wrote this
article in Spanish and I'm
translating him into English;
these are the baroque
inversions that you can get in
this course, too.
This is what Peter Dunn said in
my own translation into English:
"What is observed,
in the cave of Montesinos
episode, is quixoticism from the
inside.
He looks at himself in the
mirror of his madness where
comedy and spectator merge and
the enchanter and the enchanted
coalesce.
Far from offering us an image
of eternity, Montesinos' cave
constitutes a frozen
temporality.
Don Quixote will have to return
to his own bed,
and dream the dream of death so
Alonso Quixano can awaken,
purged of his dreams and ready
to contemplate himself without
theater in the mirror of
eternity."
This is anticipating the death
of Alonso Quijano at the end of
the book.
Anthony Cascardi,
an American hispanist,
links the episode to the dream
argument in Descartes and makes
quite a few valuable
observations about Don Quixote
as a whole,
particularly about the entire
debate about the relationship
between reality and fantasy.
He says:
"I see his engagement as
with problems of skepticism and
epistemology,
and more specifically,
with the use of fiction as a
mode of knowledge of the world.
His response to skepticism and
to its complement epistemology
is to reject epistemology while
remaining anti-skeptical.
But this is only another way of
saying that its purpose is to
affirm the role of fiction in
our relationship to the world,
which, it might further be
said, is an affirmation of the
role of fiction in the task of
philosophy.
Cervantes shows that we relate
to the world,
including the world of our own
experiences,
in ways other than what the
epistemologists call knowledge,
and that all we know of the
world cannot be characterized in
terms of certainty.
Cervantes will,
to include the imagination and
dreams within the range of valid
human experience,
within what we call the world
in the broadest sense,
free of the caveats of reasons
points this up."
In short--Cascardi tends to be
a little too philosophical--
in short, that stories,
that literature are a form of
knowledge and a method of
approaching knowledge of the
world and of ourselves and a way
to understand both the world and
the workings of our own minds.
Now, psychoanalysis knows this,
and this is the reason why
Freud availed himself of figures
like the Oedipus myth,
to name mental processes,
and, of course,
Freud acknowledged that his
sources in the development and
invention of psychoanalysis,
as he was really the inventor
of it,
were literary,
and that he learned more from
literature than from the
nineteenth century science that
preceded him.
So the point is that these
stories in Montesinos cave show
that stories are valid ways of
approaching knowledge,
knowledge of the world and
knowledge of our own minds.
And this is what this episode,
I think, suggests brilliantly,
independently,
and also, of course,
within the structure of the
novel.
So much, for the time being,
for the episode of Montesinos'
cave, to which we will probably
have to allude a number of times
in succeeding lectures.
And we move now to the second
important episode that I want to
discuss today,
and that is Master Peter's
puppet show.
Now, I have made a crude
drawing on the blackboard that
will help me explain the
episode;
it is sketchy, I understand;
it is more Picasso than
Velázquez,
let's put it that way,
but you can recognize some of
the figures: that,
of course is Ginés de
Pasamonte,
that is the speaker,
the boy who speaks;
that is Don Quixote;
that is Sancho,
and then the rest of the
audience, and,
of course, the puppet show as
best as I could render it.
Now, the reappearance of
Ginés de Pasamonte
establishes a concrete
continuity with Part I.
Other than Sancho,
the women of Don Quixote's
house,
the priest and the barber,
Ginés is the only
character from Part I who comes
back in Part II.
If before Ginés was a
rogue picaresque author,
a Mateo Alemán--remember
Mateo Alemán,
the author of Guzmán
de Alfarache;
remember that I said in that
episode of the galley slaves
when he says he has written his
life, he's a Mateo
Alemán.
If before Ginés was a
rogue picaresque author,
a Mateo Alemán,
he is now as Master Peter,
a miniature playwright,
a Lope de Vega in miniature--
remember, Lope de Vega,
Cervantes' enemy and the great
Spanish playwright of the
period.
As both, Alemán and
Lope,
Ginés stands for the
modern author,
whose not an aristocrat or a
cleric and has to earn a living
from his craft.
Lope liked to put the "de
Vega" in his last name to
pretend that he was
aristocratic,
and he made up fables about his
family and all of that,
but he was not.
Ginés also stands for
Cervantes himself,
and the whole episode is like a
laboratory for fiction to carry
out experiments about fiction,
as Cervantes tends to do,
and we have seen.
Ginés is wily;
he does not respect literary
tradition or rules,
and shows the limitations
imposed by the medium of
literature.
Like the imagined friend of the
1605 prologue--
remember the imagined friend
whom Cervantes says comes to
visit him and helps him write
that prologue--
this modern author does not
have a conventional or a deep
classical education and has to
rely on compendia and books of
familiar quotations for his
erudition.
Lope was known for this,
to get his information here and
there pretend that he had read a
lot.
He read a lot,
but not in the way that
humanists had read a great deal,
and he made it up the way that
the friend tells Cervantes in
the prologue,
to just go and get this book
and that and then just make a
list of sources in alphabetical
order,
and that's the way these modern
authors operate.
Now, Ginés has now one
eye covered.
This is why I have--well,
actually I have the wrong eye
covered;
it's supposed to be the left
eye that is covered,
so, to be true to him,
we'll uncover this eye and
cover this eye,
the left eye.
He has one covered,
presumably the one that pulled
in and made him cross-eyed,
because he knows that this is a
distinctive trait that is
dangerous for him to display.
He can be spotted,
described and nabbed by the
Holy Brotherhood,
so he has to disguise himself;
this is why he has to
cover--it's sort of his
signature, his body signature
which is that he's cross-eyed,
like having a prominent scar or
something.
Remember the description of Don
Quixote that the trooper reads
when he's about to arrest him,
towards the end of Part I,
he has a description;
so a description of
Ginés will probably begin
by saying: he is cross-eyed,
so he has to cover that eye to
be safe.
Ginés is a fugitive from
justice.
Remember, he is one of the
galley slaves that Don Quixote
set free,
so whatever other crimes he
committed to make him be a
galley slave,
he has also escaped.
Hence, I quote:
"I had forgot to tell you
[this is from the book]
that this same Master Peter had
his left eye and almost half his
cheek covered with a patch of
green taffeta,
a sign that something ailed all
that side of his face."
That's from the text of the
Quixote.
But being one-eyed,
as it were, even if it is
faked, suggests fresh
restrictions that impinge his
art because of his limited
perception of reality.
I am sort of glossing over my
article in the Casebook
that you have read,
presumably, by now.
This deformity also makes him
look furtive,
dangerous, sneaky,
and, of course,
aesthetically interesting,
like the characters in Part I
and those in Velázquez's
paintings.
He is no Renaissance idealized
model of a man,
although it is said several
times that he is a gallant and
good looking man,
but he's cross-eyed.
Before, Ginés converging
side access distorted
reality--we have gone over this.
Now, he lacks depth perception,
which is very suggestive to the
show that he will stage at the
inn.
Ironically, by eliminating one
eye, Ginés is overcoming
the problem of non-converging
sidelines;
it is a radical way of doing so
but now he lacks perspective.
Remember, that bi-ocular sight
you see with two eyes,
therefore you have potentially
a double vision;
and there are,
because of this,
there are,
in some cultures,
deities that overcome this by
having a pineal eye,
which is an eye in the middle
of the forehead that sort of
serves to mediate between these
two.
So, in the case of
Ginés,
he is eliminating this eye to
have only one eye,
and therefore only one vision,
where before,
as a cross-eyed,
his access did not meet:
they were supposed to meet here
but they don't quite meet,
and therefore he saw it in a
distorted way,
but now with only one eye,
as we know,
he loses depth.
Now, the whole episode of the
puppet theater is besides yet
another critique of Lope de
Vega,
a protracted experiment on
mimesis like that of Princess
Micomicona,
and not just in literary terms
but also in pictorial terms.
But as a critique of Lope
Cervantes, again,
harps upon the carelessness
with which Lope used history to
write his plays.
Remember the episode with the
Canon of Toledo where there was
a protracted discussion and
critique of Lope for just
grabbing historical elements
pell-mell without being very
faithful to history.
When Don Quixote protests in
the middle of the show that it
is wrong to have Moors ringing
bells instead of kettle drums,
Master Peter answers with what
contemporaries were surely not
to miss as an allusion to Lope
de Vega.
It says:
"Señor Don Quixote,
[says Ginés de Pasamonte
from within the puppet theater]
do not criticize upon trifles,
nor expect that perfection,
which is not to be found in
these matters.
Are there not a thousand
comedies acted almost
everywhere,
full of as many improprieties
and blunders,
and yet they run their career
with great success,
and are listened to,
not only with applause but with
admiration?
Go on, boy, and let folks talk;
[he's now addressing the boy],
go on, boy, and let folks talk;
for, so I fill my bag.
I care not if I represent more
improprieties than there are
motes in the sun."
Now, this is as clear an
allusion to Lope de Vega as
could be made,
and remember that Avellaneda,
as I mentioned before,
may have been a follower and a
defender of Lope de Vega,
and this is why he wrote in his
prologue such insulting comments
about Cervantes.
Now, as a laboratory of mimesis
the show that Maese Pedro and
his assistant put on is of a
conceptual complexity worthy of
the Velázquez of Las
Meninas and The
Spinners,
which you have seen here.
To begin with,
we have that the performance of
the puppets is not enough in
itself,
and that Master Peter's figures
and props require a supplemental
oral commentary or narrative
executed by his assistant:
this is the assistant.
I put a little balloon here,
as in comic books,
because this is what he's
saying.
Of course, if I may be allowed
to use his convention from
comics.
So he needs the supplemental
narrative by the
trujamán,
was the word of the period.
But the visual and verbal
representations do not harmonize
properly,
and both Don Quijote and
Ginés have to admonish
the boy,
who is the author's
supplementary voiceover.
It's like a voiceover in a
film, but it is as if the
voiceover and the film images
didn't quite mesh.
It is a dual performance of the
author's invention.
That is, the author's
invention, which is
Ginés,
here, is manifested in two
ways--which is manifested
visually and orally at the same
time,
hoping that they will
complement each other.
But they do not mesh
satisfactorily,
as if there were an inherent
flaw in the recital that
reflects the awkwardness of the
theatrical routine.
It's very awkward to represent
the stories with these material
objects that represent human
beings,
so what we have here is a very
flawed combination of the oral
and the visual trying to
combine,
to produce a performance,
a satisfactory performance.
To produce mimesis,
representation,
and it is a critique of mimesis
and representation;
this is what I'm trying to say.
Don Quixote's correction to the
boy is significantly made in the
language of geometry as applied
to painting.
Don Quixote says:
"Here Don Quixote said in
a loud voice:
'Boy,
boy, on with your story in a
straight line,
and leave your curves and
transversals:
for,
to come at the truth of a fact,
there is often need of proof
upon proof'."
Unquote.
What could seem like a mere
rhetorical display on the part
of the knight is,
on the contrary,
of surprising propriety in the
context of the episode,
because the whole effect of the
puppet show depends on a visual
trompe-l'oeil--
it's a French expression for a
trick,
trompe-l'oeil,
you use it in English;
trampantojo,
is an old work in Spanish,
it's the same,
"trampa"
and "ojos,"
trampantojos.
We don't use it any more in
Spanish,
we use trompe-l'oeil,
the French word,
most of the time,
but it's based on a visual
trompe-l'oeil or a visual
trick based on perspective,
exactly the way that a painting
is organized according to
geometrical rules that produce
the effect of mass and depth--
I hope you follow this:
Geometrical rules of the
painting,
we've talked about the book by
Alberti,
produce the effect of mass and
depth by distance.
Master Peter himself,
by the way, agrees with Don
Quixote,
and his admonition to the boy
also appeals to the language of
geometry and painting:
"Boy,
none of your flourishes,
but do what the gentlemen bids
you;
for that is the surest
way."
"Flourishes"
is "dibujos,"
or drawings,
in the original.
Don Quixote and Ginés'
words say more than they know a
common occurrence in Cervantes,
as we have seen many times.
The puppet show's effect,
its verisimilitude,
is based on a question of
proportions and perspective,
and has a great deal to do with
a straight a line that Don
Quixote demands that the boy
narrator follow without much
success.
It is a metaphor,
of course, to apply straight
line to how a story unfolds,
a narrative unfolds.
The narrative straight line and
the straight line that can be
drawn from the spectators to the
show are related.
That is, this is the straight
line from the spectators to the
show as they look at it,
and I'm relating that to the
straight line in the story that
Don Quixote refers to when he
admonishes the boy.
If the spectators look directly
at the theater to engage in its
fantasy,
they have to disregard that at
such a short distance human
figures,
horses and buildings,
should appear so small,
as if they were much further
away.
Perspective has to be assumed
as if different geometric
relations between the public and
the tiny actors obtained,
as if the geometric physical
relations between the spectators
and the show were different than
they are because they're so
close.
The narrator goes through
"curves and
transversals,"
as Don Quixote calls them,
to achieve the illusion of
simultaneous action taking
place,
and to hold the spectators
attention and approval in the
same way that the theater has to
abuse the rules of geometry to
stage the action--
abuses the rules of geometry to
stage the action in what is
presumably a greater territory,
but it is compressed on the
stage, and the proportion
between the various elements,
the various--the actors and the
horses and all of that,
are not followed.
Ginés cannot vary the
figures dimensions as they come
closer or further away from the
public,
the dimensions are a given that
cannot be changed.
This whole ensemble of virtual
lines,
like those in
Velázquez's painting,
hold up the fiction and its
props at the same time in front
of the audience.
The audience here is aware both
of the fiction and of the props
that are there to make up the
fiction,
is what I'm trying to say,
as in Velázquez's
paintings.
To sustain the illusion the
narrator not only avails himself
figuratively of the geometric
figures,
but also of the rhetoric of
visions repeating the anaphora
like--
anaphora is a rhetorical figure
when you repeat a word or a turn
of phrase: "let us not
forget...,
let us not forget...,
" the orator will repeat
something like that;
that is an anaphora,
and here the language of
visions in medieval literature
used this figure and the boy
says: "Pray
observe...,"
"See him now...,"
"Turn your eyes
toward...,"
"Now behold...,"
"Do you not see...,"
"Behold now...,"
"Observe that..."
What he's really telling them,
with all of these repetitions
is: but don't actually see what
is really happening,
overlook it to be able to
accept the fiction.
Within the very illusion of a
show we have a kind of mirror
duplication of the problem of
perspective and vanishing point.
Remember that I talked about
vanishing point in Las
Meninas about the gentleman
who's at the very end,
who is literally leaving and
vanishing,
so there would seem to be a pun
there.
This becomes literal when
Melisandra and Don Gaiferos,
who are on the same horse,
gallop desperately running away
from the Moors towards
"la línea de
Francia,"
towards the line dividing
France from Spain,
the border.
So if they are on the horse,
here, they're moving towards
the back of the stage towards a
vanishing point,
so this is literalized here the
vanishing point in the fiction,
that is being depicted in the
story.
Now, all of these tricks manage
to confuse Don Quixote,
of course, who predictably
lunges towards the action to
participate in it,
caught in a net of rhetorical
and geometrical figures that
have blinded him not letting him
see the difference in size
between his own body and those
of his enemies:
he has lost the sense of
proportion,
and this is what encourages him
other than his madness,
of course, to participate in
the action.
This is, by the way,
this scene of Don Quixote
lunging on to the stage,
is the one that Orson Welles
used in his attempted film on
the Quixote.
Orson Welles never finished his
Quixote,
but there are parts that he
filmed,
and I spoke about them in a
symposium on Orson Welles here,
a couple of years ago,
and got to see some of them,
and this is one of them,
and what he has,
the scene takes place in a
movie, a movie that is being
shown outdoors,
actually, and Don Quixote
climbs on the stage and slashes
at the screen in this modern
adaptation of this famous scene.
I think that Cervantes projects
himself in Ginés Master
Peter as author of modern
fictions.
As he had already done in the
galley slaves episode in Part I,
to not overlook that Cervantes
was also maimed,
like Ginés is cross-eyed
and Cervantes,
as you remember,
had a lesion on his left arm
that he couldn't use.
Ginés Master Peter is
struggling with the hardships of
authorship,
as it were, by adjusting his
ability to perceive reality,
hence to represent it.
Making himself one-eyed,
Master Peter manages to prevent
the problems created by his
cross-eyedness.
Remember that with two eyes,
let alone their being crossed,
there are two visions,
which may or may not coincide,
but certainly will not if he is
cross-eyed;
we have gone over this.
This is the cause of his not
being able to foresee and ending
to his
autobiography–remember?
He says, 'how can my
autobiography be finished if my
life is not?'
You could project that as a
problem of vision,
too, if autobiography goes this
way and life that way,
and you have a vision that
doesn't allow for a coincidence
of the two,
that infinitely receding end of
the fiction,
or infinitely to the end of his
life,
could be seen as part of his
problems with his eyes.
With only one eye,
however, Master Peter would be
able to look straight through
only one visual access,
but this is not a happy
solution either.
To compensate for his loss of
one-half of the visual field he
must look sideways:
if he has his eye covered he
has to look sideways,
askew in his head.
He cannot achieve a harmonious
vision, and he makes himself
more awkward and interesting,
hence he cannot represent
reality properly.
With only one eye Master Peter
cannot create a perspective that
will correspond to reason,
to follow Alberti's treatises
on painting that I mentioned.
His reading of literary
tradition is also askew,
like the tilt of his head.
We also know that with only one
eye he would also lose his depth
perception, which would
disastrously affect his capacity
to create perspective.
His rewriting of the Melisendra
and Gaiferos story is fraught
with errors, like Lope de Vega's
plays which Don Quixote tries to
correct, as we saw.
Only that ideal reader,
Alonso Quijano,
who, instead of writing
romances of chivalry tried to
act one out,
can see straight in the lucid
nights of his library and
perceive fictions that are
harmonious and very similar
within themselves and to
himself.
Don Quixote,
in the darkness of Juan
Palomeque's inn,
by slashing the wineskins,
makes the various fictional
levels converge and resolve the
conflictive stories.
It is the ability to fuse all
of those non-converging levels
of fiction that makes Cervantes
such a great modern author,
whose fictions will not destroy
themselves from within,
as Ginés' does here.
Cervantes' is a happy
cross-eyedness,
because the various lines do
not fuse in his imaginative
world, yet cohere in some way.
To him, the origin of vision is
always already a double vision,
with irony being congenital to
it, with representation
depending on it.
I like to see this whole
episode of Master Peter's puppet
show as an allegory of the whole
of the Quixote,
with Cervantes the author
hidden inside there,
but outside his fiction,
which he controls through
strings with a voice projected
by an agent,
Cide Hamete Benengeli or his
translators,
whom he cannot quite control
either.
The story itself,
like that of Melisandra and
Gaiferos,
is drawn from literary
tradition but distorted and
rearranged as needed,
and the public,
we, the readers,
are drawn into this fiction,
but not completely aware as we
are of the artifice of the whole
construct.
I am moved, romantic that I am,
with Cervantes' identification
with Ginés,
the fugitive from justice,
roaming through Spain
struggling to make a living with
this fiction making contraption.
Now, Cervantes wraps up this
take on modern literature and
its labors in the brilliant
scene that closes the episode of
Master Peter's puppet show,
the one in which aided by
Sancho and the innkeeper Don
Quixote compensates the
puppeteer for the figurines that
he has smashed.
The value of each broken piece
depends on his or her relative
importance in the fiction,
not on its material value based
on the stuff of which it is
made,
plus the workmanship.
Charlemagne is worth a great
deal because of who he is in the
story, for instance.
The real and the fictional
worlds cut through each other
here.
Real money is being paid in
restitution for damages,
but the amount of the
compensation is figured on
fictional values--Do you
understand what I mean?
I mean, a slave,
or a peasant,
or a servant would not--a
figurine, even if it's beautiful
and big, would not cost as much
as that of the king.
What Cervantes seems to be
underlining here is the value of
fictional characters as
creations by their author.
How much would a Don Quixote or
a Sancho be worth to Cervantes?
How much a Hamlet to
Shakespeare?
How much would it take to
compensate García
Márquez for Coronel
Aureliano Buendía,
or Borges for Pierre Menard?
These are fictional entities,
but now they have a real
monetary value in a world in
which literature is becoming a
commodity,
without ceasing to be,
at the same time,
one of the great expressions of
the human spirit.
This scene is reminiscent of
the one in Part I towards the
end when restitutions are made
to the barber whose basin has
been taken,
to the innkeeper for expenses
and damages and marriage vows
are exchanged to make up for
Fernando's dishonest behavior
towards Dorotea.
It is a miniaturized scene of
restitutions,
a small-scale repetition of
that scene in Part I.
To me, it is as if Cervantes
were boasting of how many ways
he can rewrite episodes in Part
II, and he is certainly a master
puppeteer himself.